la mobilisation baisse peut-être mais
elles continuent samedi après samedi
aujourd'hui c'est le douzième acte une
journée de mobilisation particulière
puisque cette semaine l'exécutif a fait
savoir qu'il maintenait la possibilité
de recourir aux passes jusqu'à l'été
2022 à paris plusieurs cortèges dont
celui organisé par des jd jaune où l'on
retrouve notre reporter gaiement aussi
bonjour à guesnain alors quelle est
l'ambiance sur place
et bien mr à l'ambiance pour le moment
elle est parfaitement bonne aucun
incident absolument aucun incident a
déclaré qui parmi les le millier de
personnes environ qui a rejoint seul
corps tâche au cortège qui est parti d
environ une heure de la place
denfert-rochereau et unis se dirigent
lentement vous le voyez passer derrière
moi vers la place de la nation situé à
quelques kilomètres km de là dans la
foule mais on entend les slows du les
slogans étaient en mai bien connue des
gilet jaune depuis le début du mouvement
mais également de nouveaux slogans anti
face sanitaires ils n'en veulent pas
c'est en tout cas ce qu ils scandent
depuis le départ du cortège presque en
continu mais le pass sanitaire n'est pas
la seule source de mécontentement de ces
manifestants je vous propose d'écouter
le co-organisateur de la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui
les revendications ne sont pas
simplement contre le pasteur il ya aussi
des revendications sociales puisque le
prix du gaz en fait il a augmenté de 57%
le prix de l'électricité il a augmenté
de 12% et y ait une réforme dation de
l'assurance chômage qui rentre en
vigueur depuis le 1er octobre qui
pénalise en fait les demandeurs d'emploi
l'inter le président de la république
sait qui est plus de contestation
sociale qui n'est plus une manifestation
donc je crois que tout le monde l'a
contraint en fait que s'il est le prix
du gaz a été gelée c'est qu'ils
craignent en fait le retour des jets les
jaunes et les manifestations sur toute
la france puisque le gaz ça concerne
qu'une bonne partie de la population
donc c'est un tout c'est la liberté et
la justice sociale aujourd'hui on peut
se demander si en fait la prolongation
du passé ni terre qui est à
contre-courant je vois là par rapport
aux cibles et santé publique n'est pas
un leurre en vue de la présidence et
l'on s'interroge pas parce qu'il ya là
aucun motif en fait de prolonger
jusqu'en 2022 le pacer semaines cette
manifestation elle vient ponctuer une
semaine un peu particulière un peu
symbolique il ya l'extension du pass
sanitaires aux adolescents entre 12 et
17 ans ce qui concerne environ 5
millions de jeunes et puis la fameuse
question de la prolongation de ce pass
sanitaire au delà du 15 novembre
gabriela talent a évoqué le sujet
mercredi dernier le porte parole du
gouvernement qui a confirmé que vous
l'avez dit amirali l'exécutif comptait
conserver la possibilité de se servir de
ce pass sanitaire jusqu'à l'été 2022
donc sans compter les annonces sociales
les gilets jaunes ont du grain à moudre
cette semaine
merci guillemin pour toutes ces
précisions
[Musique]